okay guys um
i have felt like crap all day and i
literally thought that i was gonna fall
asleep but i can't
um
okay
let's see
oh i should move my
so
i'm just kind of gonna see if anyone
wants to come on
let me go onto my channel and make sure
this is working
so
okay
just
curious you guys hear this
just curious
can you guys hear this
okay no clearly not
um
okay so you guys are welcome to and ask
me any questions um while you're on the
live
otherwise i'm just going to talk about
things that have happened to me in my
life and um
you guys can react as you see fit
um
so lately i've been kind of going
through like a little bit of a mental
rough patch like genuinely
mentally um
i don't know moving countries and like
doing a long distance relationship and
like feeling very alienated from a lot
of my friends has just been like hard
um
and i don't know like i feel like in the
last year
like a lot of the comment section gets
to me more than like i really like to
admit
and it's kind of hard because i think as
a girl like we naturally
like words i think naturally like affect
us more than men really do
to be honest um
and it's something that i kind of have
to like learn to like shut off
um
but especially like in the type of
content that i'm in it's
it can be particularly like difficult at
times if i'm being honest
um so my account got popular for a
couple of reasons lately
i haven't i've really just been posting
old tic-tocks but
um
let's see so my account got popular when
i was doing like rap reactions for a
while and then it also got popular when
i was doing
red pill kevin samuels reactions um and
then a lot of my tick tocks have been
actually going viral lately i got one to
a million views which is actually pretty
crazy
craziest part is that on youtube um
or on tick tock where it was originally
posted it got maybe 10 000 views but on
youtube it got a million which is
pretty insane actually
um i don't know why i've been wanting to
freestyle on a live lately
and i've been literally thinking about
this because i feel like i'm better than
people would think but i'm also not that
good either
but
i don't know
what was i going to look at
but initially my account got popular
because of
the rap reactions i would say my youtube
channel like started blowing up last
year
but it kind of died down a little bit
i wonder
like an easy
oh my gosh are you one of those average
at best types that doesn't know that
they're average i actually know
that i am average and i would say i have
particularly like low self-esteem to be
honest like i'm not overly confident so
i would probably say that i'm average to
below average if i'm being honest
um
what i want to look up
what up ellie
um recently though somebody
actually offered to help me edit which
was like the nicest thing
like for free which is kind of crazy
by the 25th of the month i think i
claimed it already
this is the problem with reacting to
other people's content is you get so
many copyright strikes like constantly
um
today i did public interviews and let me
tell you in the uk it is much harder to
get people to stop and do a public
interview
than it is in the u.s
um
so
oh my gosh
they tell you
oh my gosh yeah in the uk people are not
as nice by any means like at least in
public being like friendly and stuff
oh my gosh did it go
huh
it's interesting because
on my live it says you guys cannot see
my screen can you not see it
um
okay let me
oh yeah you can you can okay
i'm going to do easy
easy freestyle beads
i like loki i feel like i could be a
rapper
i feel like i could
but like a bad one
should i do it should i
ah no i'm too scared i'm too scared i
can't not alive
um
what should i react to though actually
i was thinking about
things i could do on this live that
would be fun
ew
richard put coke on this thing before
intimacy that is so gross
oh my god
you would have enjoyed the wrap should i
do it don't don't gasp me up guys i kind
of want to
um
i kind of
i
okay i did easy because
should i do it
dude dude
give me a word in the chat
should i do it ah
no no i get too nervous i can't
um wait i think the baby is the one that
my
boyfriend
i'm getting
okay
i kind of like the speed
hey what's up i'm the new sensation
hey what's up i'mma take a vacation
hey what's up
alienation
staycation i'm the type of [ __ ] to go
to the club
meet a boy there go home with the thug
and after i'll tell oh my god i can't do
it anymore i can't that was it that was
your two seconds i get too nervous
um
abba and preach stage passing
age passing
um
she peed on stage
oh my god should i do like a 24-hour
thanksgiving stream
that'd be kind of interesting
um
wait
and pee's in his mouth
no
no
oh
oh
my god
not
did he sign up for this i am so confused
uh
oh my god i
does anyone else get pee shy i can't
even watch the rest of this that is so
disgusting
oh my god that is so gross
what should i watch
oh i watched this today rational mail
oh my gosh i actually wanted to have him
on my channel
um
i don't think he'd come on to be honest
like i feel like
after listening to him i don't think he
really
enjoys collaborating with girls um
mostly because
i think he
i forgot he used the word one of his on
one of his shows just how we like
hear things emotionally first and he
hears things logically first so like
when you
bring us together um
a lot of times people like
like girls have to like be caught up
with like the terminology
um
do i watch anime
no
i've actually been trying to learn to
cook recently
donovan sharp
i could ask i feel like
i don't think he'd have me on because of
the video i did on or i don't even want
to come on his platform like i would but
i don't think he'd want me on it
um but i feel like because i did the
video on fresh and fit
that he wouldn't want to come on i just
have
have this
gut feeling which is fine i don't
you know
it was fun watching me react to sports
meet canyon
huh
so
is this supposed to be funny
oh
um ellie you need to go outside
what you
i hope not
um is my mom
or my boyfriend
red pill
no he hates this stuff
do
oh my god this is so weird
i know but you said
s-y-s-b-m and when i googled that it's
like the mgtow red pill guide so that's
what i figured you're asking
do
oh
oh dear
that's not that is not where i saw this
going
oh my god that's the weirdest thing i've
watched in a while
ellie do you need to go outside
looks like all right guys i'm gonna low
low-key leave this live going
probably against better judgment
and i'm gonna go let my dog out if you
wanna stay
feel free if not i get it it'll take me
like two minutes
you
oh my gosh
are you happy ellie
are you happy
guys my dog is not um huge she's a
little english bulldog
um
okay let's see who you guys said
i'm an elevator this isn't a house this
is an apartment well it's a flat
technically i'm in the uk now
did i walk my dog no um i got i was
talking to the front desk person
for a second
is your penis too small
in honest video oh my god
what
what
i just want to get to that
oh my god 16 minutes this is too much
alexander
i just want to know what the answer is
so
oh my god
okay this is what my dad says
how does this information help you like
what if the answer is yes your penis is
too small
how does that information help you like
you can't
you can't make it bigger
like
you just get what you get it's like
boobs like
what am i i could get a boob job but if
i don't want to do that like
what am i supposed to do
okay what should i watch
the future of dating
oh thank you fight experience i've
actually
oh it looks like i've watched this clip
before but let me i've watched so many
youtube videos like when i clean and
stuff i just let them like
play so sometimes i listen to stuff and
only like half watch it
is this a q a yeah if you put questions
and answers in the chat
i'd be happy to do that
hmm
yes
you can't hear anything
you can't hear rolo
oh okay what about now
it's the headphones um let's see if i
can fix it
um
odd
did it work then when i turned up the
sound
was it just quiet before
wait okay wait let me
oh you're right
oh it's only working because you can
hear the mic like through the headphones
i hate
tech stuff i literally hate tech stuff
okay
um
[Music]
weird
let me
do
audio input capture
audio output capture okay let me add
this and see if that makes it better
um
a friend who was here earlier you know
yesterday
um uh what about that what's happening
is you're seeing the um you're seeing
sort of like the social
narrative what about now furtive and the
social you know fabric kind of react to
this the new sexual marketplace so it's
gonna be okay
for one woman to have full
um
did it work yay
[Music]
if i was single um
i don't know like
i'm 25 so like 45 maybe
um
it definitely okay the one thing i have
a question about in mgtow so they're
very much into the um
the
i'll start it over yeah that's fine and
um okay so
in the manosphere people are very much
um
into like statistics and one of the
stats that's like constantly thrown
around is um
that
merit 50 of marriages end in divorce so
be wary of marriages that's fine do you
guys think the same with age gap dating
because the numbers actually say you're
more likely to divorce if there's a
bigger age gap
but the menosphere like seems to be very
much in favor of age gap dating so it's
interesting because the stats like don't
back that up
but anyways let me know in the comments
[Music]
i think first off you have to look at
what the trends are in the sexual
marketplace um even tim poole and and
mike service talked about this on that
show which is um you're gonna have the
winners and the losers and the top 20
well he 10 20 percent of guys let's just
say 20. yeah 80 to make it easier just
to make it easy the top 20 percent of
guys are going to be the guys who are
going to be doing all the [ __ ] okay
um we're already seeing this happen
we're already seeing a return to a
pre-monogamy uh sexual marketplace uh
i've written at least three different uh
okay wait so it says because the age gap
is biologically respectful
but
biologically wouldn't you say marriage
like over the course of history has been
like a good thing and like been good for
nature
um
so i mean i i don't have a problem with
age gap dating honestly like i i've
never done it but i
i wouldn't be opposed um it just makes
me like like okay everyone in the
manosphere
seems to think that like age gap dating
is like the best like option but if it
was
why did the numbers support that the
most successful marriages are the same
age to two years apart
um
just you know food for thought i guess
one of them is actually in here in book
four um about polygamy uh like paulie
like we call it something cute we don't
call prostitutes prostitutes anymore we
call them sex workers we don't call it
uh polygamy anymore we call it poly
because polyamory sounds cuter and nicer
and and and it makes people feel better
because we're all about feelings right
now right but that's the it's it's a
cute way of saying that there's going to
be guys who are like puke said way back
in the day is
um you know women would rather share a
successful alpha than be saddled with a
faithful beta and guess what in a
gynocentric social order they don't have
to be saddled with a faithful beta
you're asking me about like last names
and surnames and stuff that's an
indicator of that right there they don't
have to take your name anymore just as
as as fresh was saying a minute ago it's
like women don't have to worry about the
beta bucks provisioning side of things
because they're over represented in in
college they're over represented in the
american war workplace they're
overrepresented in high-profile you know
rewarding jobs not raw sewage or
construction but hr like our good
girlfriend who was here earlier
yesterday
um but what's what's happening is you're
seeing the um you're seeing sort of like
the social
narrative and the social you know fabric
kind of react to this the new sexual
marketplace so it's gonna be okay for
one woman to have four beta chumps who
want to be in a poly relationship a
three bowl right throuple or quadruple i
don't know what the hell they even call
it right or you're gonna have guys like
the dude that's in uh the netherlands
right now who's selling his sperm for
three hundred dollars a shot right so
that women so that women who are aged
out of the sexual marketplace can have
babies when they're like in their 30s
and 30s like the dude is like wow that
is a real problem it was because i read
it was an article i think i don't want
to say what's the new york times was
something and maybe was a bbc i think is
what it was um the guy is uh selling his
jizz on on facebook
and meets up meets up with these girls
gives them a sample then she impregnates
herself is he like a tall good looking
guy apparently that's and that's and so
rather than have like a sperm bank he
just he's just a free agent right
but it's causing a problem because now
700 kids in the in holland are his are
half brothers and half sisters of that
one guy
but they're all those women and so the
market if you look at like women's
nature why are they all going to this
one guy because he's a hot young guy
that they would otherwise have liked to
have reproduced with it [ __ ] but they
don't need him for financial or like the
three p's they don't need it for
provisioning protection or or uh
parental investment because they either
get it through the state or they get it
through their beta lovers or
the dad who stepped up right we
reinforce those narratives to say that a
guy who uh
sublimates his paternal interests is a
superhero
okay um going back to the conversation
we were having before i'm just reading
the comments um
if you have a high concentration of
people who are married with age gaps
then you will
get more people with age gaps who will
end up in divorce but no it's saying
that um
okay it says the bigger the age gap the
more likely for a divorce so when
there's no difference in age
um
it's normal when there's one year in age
it's three like there's no
like you're not more
likely um one year three percent more
likely five years difference 18 more
likely 10 years 39 more likely 20 years
95 more likely and 30 years 172 percent
more likely so it just begs the question
like why
if
age gap dating
is such a good thing and again i don't
have a dog in this fight i
i don't care who people date but the
question is like why aren't the results
better
um in the distant past girls were
married off at 12 or 16 with an older
man with land and cattle by 20 shoes and
mother of four okay well do we want to
go back to that what does that matter
um
so what types of media content creation
would you want to do for a company um
gosh i've never
i i'd be open to like a lot of different
types of content for a company um i like
testing out products so
like you let me try your product for a
week i make a video testing it
um it's called gold diggers but the best
isn't
okay because he's pointed at me
i'm not saying you oh my god i'm so
bored by this clip i already know what
they're gonna say that women are gonna
like end up single
because they're all hooking up with the
same 10 to 20 percent of guys
sorry guys i just
i know i i've heard enough of this stuff
that it becomes
so repetitive and like boring almost at
times
a woman who is
has severe disfigured
a woman who has
a severe disfigured can try super hard
to be feminine and pretty but she's
still getting left behind same for a
very short man man
okay yeah probably
marriage is not good in today's world
thank you for watching this please
finish to the end
um
i really just i've seen it before that's
the only thing is i have
how bad it is i know
like it's the same thing five to twenty
percent of men are getting laid
because you're my bo you're not even a
father you're my biological sample
provider or whatever it is right so that
so you have this as
as the realities of the sexual
marketplace and what happens is the
social
fabric reacts to that
so you'll have you'll get egg freezing
right you'll get um uh what i even
quoted this uh with you cappy was um
the the rise of the she economy right
yes and and uh morgan stanley is
predicting that what is it a 40 is it 42
all right if i keep watching this and it
says exactly what
exactly what i said it was going to say
i'm going to be irritated i'm just
letting you five percent i
thought it was the age range was from 25
to 44 was the age range
all right then i want to say i want to
say the percentage 25 42 or 52 we'd have
to look at that i think anyways it's a
substantial proportion of women between
the eight working age women
which they
you know uh target as 25 to 44 will be
single and childless by 2030.
exactly
predicting what you were just saying a
minute ago
and that's no way to run a society
when our family korea well i mean if you
look at western societies they've been
based on the well
an approximation let's just say of a
nuclear family a mother a father kids
and and we worked with we worked within
that uh what jordan peterson is called
socially enforced monogamy again it's
not we got a force
for that saying that well it's because
they misinterpreted it because they look
like you remember what i said about like
cutesy little terms yeah that was one of
them they jumped all the way like when i
say punish bad behavior you know what
i'm saying rather that rather than go
what is he really saying by that is that
actually a sociological psychological
term yes it is but let's jump all over
and exactly yeah cause it makes us feel
bad yeah but yeah so so you've got that
and in a gynocentric social lottery i
agree with cap i think that we're going
to see more and more division and more
and more segregation to the point where
there's the mgtows and doom pills are
over on this side of the playground and
the feminists and that they we don't
want to we don't want to have anything
to do with them in fact we're going to
make the society consider even these
guys these beta losers coming on to us
or like presuming to even talk to us
that's illegal so me too em
sexual harassment don't even look at us
stay in your lane you're gonna go
extinct and you should accept that
exactly we only want the hot alphas who
are at the top of the apex of the thing
right so we're getting there and we're
getting there and so how do we
facilitate that through poly
so only the women who want to get with
the hottest guys who are like the
hottest alphas because they don't need
to worry about the beta bucks side of
hypergamy anymore again mating strategy
determining the sexual marketplace
social structure determined by the
sexual marketplace
i
i don't want to be an [ __ ] here but i
feel like
this this was exactly what i said it was
going to say
small group of men getting most of the
guys
they have data to back this up
at all seeps into our religion seeps
into our politics seeps into into our
military seeps into every part of our
society because those are that's the
nuts and bolts of it
so i and i wish there was a better
solution i wish i had a better solution
for it as i said earlier i think that
men and women are better together than
we are
apart we need to accept what we are
our machinery our evolved machinery men
and women are different we need to throw
away the blank slate we need to if you
kick out the the the leg of the legs of
the blank slate and the uh and the
social con and social construction
construction
yeah
kick those two legs of the stools out of
the stool out and it all collapses oh
yeah so and so is that gonna happen i
don't know because there's too much
money being made on it there's too much
there's too many women are too ego
invested in it yeah too many beta guys
are invested in that as well so how do
we how do we bring how do we bring
people back together how do we bring how
do we tell how do you tell me i
literally feel like people i i genuinely
believe that people will come back
together um
because
at some point i do think people see the
mistakes of the generation before and
start to correct them
um the question is when tell guys who
are just like oh jesus isn't worth the
squeeze those women like we had it here
on on these uh on these super chats yeah
i'm in a really dark place right now
yeah of course you are yeah because
women are staying on that side of the
playground and you guys are staying on
this side of the playground and you hear
i hear people make these comparisons all
the time like like mgtow is just
basically the the male equivalent of
feminism and to a greater extent they
really are because
men we men need a woman like a fish
needs a bicycle right women need men
like a like a fish needs a bicycle and
you you don't have nobody's coming to
the table right now and women sure [ __ ]
aren't because they're in control they
have all the cards right yeah they do
yeah and they direct they direct
wherever you know the possibilities how
about that they don't even see these
guys that are going mgtow i i see it
like i don't have like i get it
invisible yeah it's a legit response to
a problem there is a problem in the
mating baker marketplace but what i'm
saying is that women don't even care nor
do they even know of your existence of
these guys that are going their own way
so the reality is women only see the top
10 to 20 guys anyway the guys that are
mgtow typically a lot of the times are
not even in that top 20 percentage so it
doesn't matter it's not f the only
person that's losing is you if you want
to have sex if you want to self-develop
become better i get it but women don't
care that men are going to i agree with
i agree with
with
aaron darren aaron cappy i always want
to call you cappy but um and when we say
cap by the way it means live cats like
the new captain
captain captain like when someone says
stop captain that doesn't mean that's
not an insult i mean it's like stop
lying oh lying all right yes that's a
term yeah
thank you for the donation i appreciate
it i had to get that straight to you
yeah stop captain so i i agree with it
we we we're waiting for the meteor to
hit the the planet and start everything
over again so men can be men can have a
purpose we have the lost boys generation
of purposeless young men right now
and so how do you give them purpose well
a meteorite has to hit or the flood
waters have to rise to make them have
some sort of utility in use and women
appreciate them for actually saving
their [ __ ] lives right well so that's
one one option the only other option i
can see is like try to change the social
fabric which i don't see happening
anytime and certainly not that i'll just
end with this is that um dr warren
farrell uh who i have i have a lot of
respect for dr warren ferrell but i
think he is really naive in the idea
that women are going men and women are
going to rationally rise above their
their their biologies and their
evolution and everything else and we're
going to decide to be attracted to those
those
those nihilistic self-loathing [ __ ]
and we're going to get those guys to go
you know what the juice is really worth
the squeeze and you really guys come on
we're going to go over there and talk to
those girls on that side because all we
have to do is socially convince
ourselves that we ought to be doing this
that's not how the machine evolved yep
that's what we're talking about when i
talk about like the machine i mean like
our hardware
our firmware
and then our software and software is
like what we've been taught like what we
learned from society what we learned
from our values and our parents and
every like sorry it's a taut
intelligence right
firmware is like sort of like what we're
our starting package of
our instinct kind of thing and then but
you're not going to rise above that
and the more we get set segregated the
harder it's going to be absolutely and
i'll say this real quick too guys women
fought decades to get to this point so
even if some of their belief systems are
wrong they're not going to concede any
leverage that they currently have
there's no sense there's no incentive
for them to vote for their own interests
in in politics or in any other yeah
because at the end of the day when you
leave women to their own devices they're
inherently right at the end of the day
right because it is technically the end
of the day they're going to only pick
the top 10 to 20 of men anyway so
okay if they only pick the top 10 to 20
of men why do 50 of people get married
isn't that
what they got nothing to gain by
conceding any leverage because they
don't even care that's the mission
that's what it is so
i don't even think like i'll give you an
example for me
a lot of the issues um
oh my gosh a lot of the issues that they
talk about like i can't really do
anything about so a lot of times i think
we get
so
wrapped up in like the stats
that
like
what else are you supposed to do about
it
um
i don't know
oh my god
okay i'm getting tired um
like and the crazy thing is like
a lot of the women's issues i wouldn't
even vote for so it's so interesting
when they're always talking about how um
like
women are never gonna vote against
themselves when on a lot of the women's
issues i i do and would continue to vote
against myself
um
like i have a brother that was given up
for adoption like my mom got pregnant at
17 and she could have had an abortion or
she'd give it up for adoption
and she chose to give up that kid for
adoption i i'm pro-life
i will never never in a million years be
pro-choice
um
so
it's just interesting because a lot of
like
i i know i don't represent all women and
i i don't
disagree that like a lot of girls are
pro
life or pro-choice but like my world is
very different than like the world on
the internet so
it's just like a different generation i
guess
i should enjoy my feminine privilege
um i just exist but
maybe i do i don't know
um
all right so my acne is like finally
starting to clear up
finally this side of my face is like
clear
this side
it's weird because before this year i
never had acne and then this
year um
okay so this just this
this is just to let you know what the
future will look like they should enjoy
their feminine privilege while asses
um just to get how tilted
um
just look at how tilted people got when
kevin samuels interviewed the brittany
chick or whoever that is that was a
great interview actually i really
enjoyed that um
pearly nearly every time you hear a
generalized rule you try to examine how
it applies to my life did you ever
consider that i might be an outlier most
girls are not you
don't reflect
um
yeah i definitely am an outlier that's
what i just said
like word for word
[Laughter]
um
it's the stress i think it was the
stress actually i've eaten too much
sugar my whole life
and if anything i eat better since i've
been to england then i've ate in like a
really long time
so i think it was the stress actually
um
this video shows you why we are going to
make tao i mean i feel like make the
problem with mgtow is it
it you kind of just throw in the towel
and just say oh like
there's no hope and i
i've seen guys pull girls that like you
would be surprised by
and i i would say before you go mgtow
to really like try like getting in shape
chasing like success all the like things
that
like you know like get in shape get
better at talking to people get better
like social skills like try all that
and if it doesn't work then go mgtow i
guess
well i mean do what you want i don't it
doesn't affect me but
that's what i would tell my brother
before he like would give up on girls
um how is the uk is it totally different
from the states
yes there's a lot of stuff that's
different um i haven't explored that
much to be honest i'm very stressed
about money now that i'm here like i'm
absolutely so stressed out about money
um i've probably spent like 40 50 hours
editing a video um that i'm gonna post
on my channel this week
and
yeah it's it's very stressful so
i'm hoping to make enough money the
first six months to
um pay for the second six months here
so i really have to figure out i'm
getting kind of tired of the red pill
content to be honest
so i kind of want to go
i wouldn't mind having some red pill
themes on my channel but
i'm just getting tired of reacting to
like the same people talking about the
same stuff
so i kind of want to go a slightly
different direction on my channel but i
haven't figured out what um
aaron cleary
i don't know who that is um said that
only two to three percent of women are
marriage material what do you think um
well 50 of women get married so
um
actually i think it's higher than that
but let's you know for this talk say
it's 50
um
i mean what do you like what do you
define as marriage material because it's
interesting i had this conversation with
my brother the other day like a lot of
red pill questions i go and i ask
um i ask my brothers right so
my older brother austin
um uh he's a oh my gosh i love him i
thank you so much for the donation um
i literally love like
we grew up together he is like one of my
favorite siblings so he lives in utah
and he makes he doesn't make six figures
but he he's i'd say with investments he
does like he's very close to that six
figure range
and he's only
20
i'm 25. so he's 27. he's about to turn
28. so that's like really good for his
age group super smart he's an engineer
um and i asked him a question that i saw
like a poll and i said
um
would you rather date a waitress or a
lawyer and he actually said a lawyer
like he prefers a girl that works hard
and is like career driven
and he really doesn't care if the girl
cooks or cleans so it's interesting
because the man of sphere said
says to me one thing right they're all
like oh we want a girl that cooks we
want a girl that cleans
and austin says he doesn't care about
any of that and he's you know i i
wouldn't say he's like a
high value guy because i think you have
to be like have a network more and i
think he has a network of like
engineer friends but
i don't think he'd be in like the the
very select category but like he's
always gonna do well he's always gonna
make a lot of money like he's very very
smart
so um
that question you'd have to define like
what is marriage material and like what
qualifications would you have
um
because most of my friends to be honest
probably wouldn't be
but it's more because most of my friends
are athletes and i think
that traditional like feminine fit
friendly like the girl that like cooks
for you cleans for you like
when you're playing sports 40 hours a
week you don't really have the time to
like develop those skills like i'm
trying to learn to cook now but like
let me tell you i if i had more time
like i wasn't a semi-pro athlete like
it would be a lot easier
um
let's see
friends who benefits women's are worth
it um
okay
oh you like the job hunt updates
actually that's really funny those tick
tocks are from like last october
i'm just reposting a lot of my tick tock
content right now you once said your
father said don't chase money chase
skills did he mean to acquire skills in
other areas um my dad actually told me
to chase things that you're interested
in and the money will come and that
you're good at like obviously don't
chase something you're not good at
um are you going to react to blackpill
and sell content next
yeah if you guys have stuff you want me
to react who send it to me on youtube it
makes it a lot easier
okay marriage material for a woman um
loyal feminine submission to her man
helps her hand man out doesn't turn sex
down from him
okay that's actually not um
as rigid as i was going to think that
someone would put in the comments
um
because loyalty feminine submissive
um to her man
helps him out
i feel like a lot of times when people
talk about submission it's really just
being like helpful
like in other words like helping him out
with stuff
not arguing when he asks you to do
something
um
[Music]
i would maybe give like i would say like
25 of women
to maybe 35 um
once again pearl anecdotes and outliers
don't speak for the generalized rule
oh my gosh i always say this
i know this is i always say i just go
from my experience
but i'm clearly an outlier in a lot of
things like i'm in a very different
world than
the rest of society
like
one i come from like a one percent
family two i come from
an athletic background so we really
didn't have like the traditional like
roles in the household because we're all
busy playing sports we compete in the
davis family
we compete um
loyalty is key
am i white yes
um
uh my an angry reaction to dating yeah
that's my boyfriend um
oh i think i got through all the
comments
for the most part
but
yeah it really confuses me when people
in the comments will be like your
personal experience isn't the world i'm
like yeah duh
even if you take a u.s experience that
is not the world like if you're in the
u.s you have a completely different
experience than someone like
that lives in brazil or africa or russia
like
duh
um
so i don't know what the n-a-w-a-l-t
proof but i'll take your word
i'll take your word for it
um
the purpose of watching this video was
to get gain a generalized empathy
um
yeah i mean
blackpill tv
let's see
not all women are like that well
duh
have you warmed up
in that mode of warming up andrei the
girl who was found that and the
boyfriend who has gone missing
and the point of this video is not the
typical missing vitamin syndrome people
already talked about that but there were
other subtle black pills in this case
that even the blackwheel community
didn't discuss enough i will also show
you guys some parts from their police
interaction video this is important
because this case this gabby bryan
couple gives you a major insight
into the desperate
um the only reason two to three percent
of marriage material is because most of
the girls leave when things get rough
they aren't loyal to their man only they
only leave when they're they leave when
they're unsure of him
plus half of them have backup options
anyway actually fun fact men also have
backup options
so when surveyed like most people have
backup options it's not just like a
woman thing
um
most uh yeah i i think characters rare i
think that people
in general don't do the right thing when
no one's watching and if they have a
choice to do the easy thing or the hard
thing a lot of them pick the easy thing
instead of the hard thing so i would say
the majority i wouldn't say two to three
percent but
i would say the majority of girls like
it like based on loyalty like no
i'm trying to think of
um
top
um i swore i'll google it just to see so
it was
backup options
i swore um
back up plans dating
um
i wish there is a survey about this and
i don't know if i can find it
um
uh men have backup options but one women
have more it's easier for women to have
backup options
women will share a man if they think
it's the best that he can get
okay wait let me let me break that down
women have more backup options true yeah
i agree
it's easier for women
it's easier for a woman to have backup
options
yeah true okay
um women will share a man if they think
he's the best she can get
um
yeah true
like i don't i don't think we disagree
um
if most of the women you surround
yourself are dusty you gotta look in the
mirror
mate
um
you talking to me
my friends aren't dusty
um
i mean
i mean i'm i've been on volleyball teams
so i definitely like have talked to a
wide variety of different types of girls
um
uh don't forget we have to earn our
backup options
if you're not born hot
yes that's true
that's true well i mean if you're born
like i'm sorry
my brothers have had options since they
were quite young like they did not
they did not have to work so yeah if
you're born unattractive as a guy
you definitely don't just get girls
throwing themselves at you
um
fifty percent of women have a backup
partner
that backup person is mostly an old
friend oh gosh
he can also be an ex-boyfriend
oh my god actually oh this is not gonna
be good okay we are often advised to
have a backup plan for everything in
life in life in case whatever
we do not have works out it seems like
women take this advice very seriously
because
a study by one pool a survey led market
research and company
okay
50 of women in a relationship have a
plan for a backup partner in their mind
in case their current relationship
doesn't work out
and they head for a breakup
oh my gosh the backup person is mostly
an old friend around a thousand women
surveyed in the uk almost 50 percent of
their participants both married as well
as unmarried women admitted to having a
back-up plan
to fall on in case they separated from
their current partner
a substantial number of participants
stated that their backup person is most
likely to be an old friend who they had
romantic feelings for in the past oh
the tea is hot
um
what is the comment says pearly will
have a long line of guys
as cape upton just the quality of guys
will differ
have a lot you're gonna put me
oh and i just understood the comment
i was about to say me and kate upton do
not have the same number of guys
interested i can promise you that um
all right one participants of the survey
also stated that their backup person can
be anyone a colleague
ex-husband school friend or man she met
at the gym what is important is that
person
has to be someone she has known for a
long time who would be ready and waiting
to be with her if the need arises
around 10 of women who participated in
this study said that their plan b rolled
around a man who might have had some at
some point of time confessed his
feelings for her around five percent
of women were confident that that the
person would drop everything to be with
her when required oh my god this is not
good this does not make us look good
ladies
what came as a big surprise is that most
of their participants share their other
half and current partner
knows and is aware of the third person
although the partner has no idea that
that is their backup plan oh god
i should do a video on this
i'm gonna like copy this
i'm gonna copy this then
um
okay wait this is just video ideas so
uh i might do that later okay
what came as a big surprise is that most
of the participants shared okay wait one
in four women participants said her
current partner has met the per third
person and a surprising number twenty
percent one in five revealed that her
partner
or husband is friends with the other man
in her life
oh my god
ladies
um
spokesperson of the research company
calls the findings a worrying sign it
says that the social media sites have
made it easier
for women to stay in touch with an old
flame however it's too early to raise
the alarm because it was not
an all-inclusive study because only 1
000 women from the uk participated in
the poll
wow
damn
what sport am i better at probably
volleyball
my shoulder's gonna fall off though
you do but you don't realize it because
the men that line up to you are
invisible to you
as said literally multiple times
the men lined up to date me
oh my gosh i don't even see anyone these
days um
this is why most western women are for
the streets
damn
oh gosh
should i go to bed i feel like i should
go to bed soon
it might be an interesting video idea
though
okay guys
this was fun um
do you guys like the streaming there's
not a ton of people on here so i don't
know if i should keep doing it or not
but
if you like the stream let me know in
the chat i will talk to you guys next
time i'm also
streaming tomorrow my volleyball game if
anyone wants to watch